please welcome Jennifer Aniston and Jack
Black
talking squirrels romantic robots and
super-powered dogs these are just a few
of the ways producers described actors
behind the backs and to those of you who
have ever thrown anything at a director
this the nominees in this category are a
reminder that we are becoming very
quickly obsolete it's not that bad
actually I make more money doing
animation than live-action really I
didn't make that much money when I did
the Iron Giant do you have some like
special animated careers strategy oh
yeah
each year I do one DreamWorks project
then I take all the money to the Oscars
embedded on Pixar
oh I'm
I'm so sorry mr. Katzenberg I don't know
why we let him out of the house this
year's nominees for Best Animated
Feature are boats
Chris Williams and Byron Howard Kung Fu
Panda John Stevenson and mark Osborne
wall-e Andrew Stanton and the Oscar goes
to Walley
um my producers Jim Morris and Lindsay
Collins should really be up here to
accept this with me it's been such an
inspiration to spend time with a
character who so tenaciously struggles
to find the beauty and everything that
he sees it's a noble aspiration to have
in times like these I dearly want to
thank everyone that's been on this film
the cast the crew everybody at Disney
and Pixar studios I have to single out a
ed catmull John Lasseter and Steve Jobs
for creating a cinematic safe haven
where only film like while it could be
made I to my wife Julie my kids been in
Andre I love you so much and I guess I'd
be remiss if I did not thank my high
school drama teacher Phil Perry for 28
years ago casting me as Barnaby and
Hello Dolly creative seeds are sown in
the oddest of places so I thank you so
much to the Academy for this
we're not gonna shot we were done now we
are going to present the award for best
animated short film which a lot of
people mistakenly think is easier to win
than the regular one but that is not
true because the shorter your movie the
less time your panda has to work its way
into America's heart did you did you
watch anything this year that you were
not in know but in my defense neither
did a lot of people ah
yeah well played mr. black well played
thank you uh the nominees for animated
short film are La Maison I'm petite cube
cuneo Kato lavatory love story
Constantine bronze it octopodes
Ahmad Mach Barry and Terry Marsh on
presto doves Sweetland
this way up Alan Smith and Adam folks
and the Oscar goes to La Maison and
petite cubes Kunio Cato
is so heavy
thank you very much thank you my
supporter thank you all my stuff thank
you my pen sir Sanka Academy thank you
animation thank you my company robot ah
domo arigato mr. Roboto thank you very
much thank you
when we return stars from two of the
biggest movies in 2008 and a look back
at the year's best moments in movie
romance here on ABC the 81st annual
Academy Awards on ABC